all right Christina Christina where you
from originally I am from um currently I
live in um the west side of Michigan I
came from a small town Heartland
Michigan uh very
rural um grew up there um but currently
I live on the west side of Michigan um
what was your family like growing up
so my parents married young I they
divorced when I was like five six um my
dad came from Puerto Rico my mom just
American white um they married young
when my dad moved here from Puerto Rico
um he moved here to work um on the
mushroom Farms with their grandfather um
he came here to work a better life or
have a better life um at that time
General Motors was like booming they
were pulling people off the streets to
work for GM so my dad and my grandfather
came up for that um my mom was underage
uh they started dating when she was like
I think 15 my dad couldn't speak any
English so his cousin had to go with
them on dates to translate and it got to
the point where they wanted to get
married and they were going to go aope
um to
Missouri and my mom had to ask for her
parents permission one um they didn't
like my dad because he was Puerto Rican
and they were racist and so they didn't
like the fact she was dating him um two
I think she was pregnant but I don't
know
um but they said okay and they had a big
wedding Catholic Church the whole big
thing um at that time my mom was working
at a hospital and then she had my sister
when they were when she
was 17 and so my sister and I are 10
years apart the one thing I will say
about my parents that I admire them for
uh is their worth work ethic they worked
hard they worked really hard um
everything 90 days same as cash no
credit cards B house you know they lived
with little they lived a modest life um
you know eventually my mom started
working for General Motors too and um
you know they built their first house
and um things were good my sister was
the son my dad never had she was treated
like a boy um she was alone with them
for 10 years and then my mom got
pregnant with me um I like to say that I
was like the Hail Mary baby only because
my mom said she couldn't get pregnant my
dad had left her my dad um loved
waitresses and so he started having an
affair with a waitress at the Coney
around the corner and he left my mom and
moved in with this waitress down the
street at this
motel and he wanted to divorce they
should have like they just they weren't
good together but my mom got pregnant
surprised it's me my dad comes home
because he's just a standup guy and
wanted to take care of me and do the
family thing so he came back had me my
sister was miserable because now here I
am this cute baby and I was Daddy's girl
so I got treated like the cute Daddy's
girl where my sister was um you know the
Tomboy um what's interesting about it
though is that my sister became really
protective over me she um would actually
sleep on my crib at night there was um
an oil fire we had like an oil furnace
back in the day and I guess it caught
fire so she was so scared that she would
sleep under my crib to make sure that
you know there was no fire I got to the
point where I would just sleep with her
so I slept with her my entire life up
until she left home
um so they built a house I was
born we moved um
to another home and this home I remember
it was cute little ranch in a really
Suburban neighborhood we were with a
Suburban family had a pool in the
backyard um everything seemed great my
mom worked day shift my dad worked
second shift um my sister was 15
14ish um but that's when I started
recognizing like the dysfunction in our
family um my dad was very abusive to my
sister I never saw him hit my mom never
saw him yell at her I never really
experienced his wrath when I was younger
um because I was so little but my sister
started getting into boys and started
getting into friends and he didn't like
that you know we weren't allowed to go
over people's houses we couldn't have
people over um that just wasn't allowed
we were very well behaved well-mannered
children we had to be so every time we
went anywhere everyone loved us to be
around because we were so well-mannered
well we were so well-mannered
because if we weren't my dad would hit
us right so his motto was be humble so
we just we couldn't smile too much we
couldn't frown too much we couldn't be
too happy we couldn't be sad we couldn't
be mad we just had to be this almost
like a reflection of whatever mood he
was in and so he was such a
charismatic social guy but so dark under
that exterior but um as far as me my mom
and I lacked any sort of emot she didn't
have an emotional bond with me she
shouldn't have been a mother she was not
a warm compassionate loving nurturing
person at all she was I'm going to teach
you how to be self-sufficient I'm going
to put a roof over your head and food on
your table and clothes on your back
that's it nothing extra that's what I'm
going to do and that's how she was um my
dad we had fun with him he was the fun
one my mom was always jealous of my
relationship with him
um it got to a point
where my dad who worked second shift
would come home and my mom would save up
all the shitty stuff my sister and I did
all day offloaded on him at night and
when he would come home after work he
would come into my sister's room our
room cuz I slept with her and he would
yank her out of bed and just start
beating her up for whatever she did
wrong so my mom like got off on it you
know she loved that [__] and
um what I think started happening is I
started recognizing what was going on
mind you I'm like four you know maybe
five almost and so when we heard my dad
coming in I would start getting really
sick like sometimes I would throw up
because I knew what was going to happen
um so what my sister started doing she
would start holding me really tight
knowing that my dad wouldn't pull her
out of bed if she was holding me so that
was her way of of saving herself so I in
sense was you know saving her and vice
versa
so it was got bloody sometimes you know
I had to witness him hurt her a lot and
um I don't have many memories of us
doing things as family then so we moved
out of that house and we m moved into
this apartment because we were having a
big house built in Heartland and um the
abuse continued on when we lived in the
apartment you know my sister was
terrible I feel bad that she had to to
go through all that
um when we had the house in Heartland
built my mom had moved up um in General
Motors so she was working there too and
she moved up to become an executive my
dad blew collar
still worked on the line made good money
but he was not flashy he was not big
house and the neighborhood we had our
house built was more affluent the
doctors the business owners you know my
best friend's dad was a ey do an
optometrist um we had two acres this
beautiful 2500 foot house on two acres
um back in the late 80s was huge deal um
but my dad really didn't want anything
to do with that it was all my mom's idea
and so I don't really remember my dad
much in that home um again he worked
second shift and he wasn't really he
wasn't around he would get me ready for
school um and those were like the
special times with him
because I'm not going to it was the
special times with him because he would
get me ready for school and do my hair
and um we would put music on and like
dance around the house and um those were
really really good
times and
uh all of a sudden he just stopped kind
of participating in the house he wasn't
he became more and more and more distant
and I remember one Christmas you know we
were opening gifts and I was like
where's dad and my mom was like oh he's
got a migraine he's not going to come
down and you know when you're young I my
concept of time I don't know how long it
was after that but my sister was working
and she got herself a job at the movie
theater locally so she was doing her
thing and
um my sister had this boyfriend that my
parents hated that was part of the
reason why my dad beat her up all the
time so I probably should have said that
my dad hated it and my Mom hated the boy
and
so my sister's boyfriend saw my dad at
the mall with another
woman and my sister told my mom and
begged my mom please don't tell Dad that
I told you and so my mom immediately
went and told my dad and said that my
sister's boyfriend saw so my mom and my
dad said you know you're lying he hates
us you know he wants us not to be
together blah blah blah and
so they got a
divorce and now we were left with
this evil awful woman who wasn't allowed
to discipline us our whole life because
that's what my dad did now this batshit
crazy woman has taken over
and she would beat my sister up all the
time so again now I'm watching my mom
beat up on my sister and my sister
she is a rock and we're completely
opposite so my mom would want a reaction
from us when she would ask us something
she'd want us to react so my sister
would just sit there and my mom would
ask her something and want a reaction my
sister would just be stone-faced and my
mom would just slap her and my sister's
head would just go like this and smack
her you know I she would not say
anything and um I got so bad that
particular day that my mom pushed her
out of the chair and started rolling
around with her on the floor beating her
up just to get the reaction from my
sister that she wanted my sister was not
giving it to her and so I'm witnessing
this it got to the point my mom picked
up the rabbit ears from the TV and just
started whipping her with it so I stood
up and I just started screaming like at
the top of my lungs because I didn't
know what else to do to make it stop and
so my mom looked at me and she's like
the windows are open you're going to
they're going to call the police think
I'm killing you and I'm like good maybe
they'll take you away you know like that
was I didn't care at that point so
shortly after that um my mom packed all
my sister's [__] in plastic bags and put
them out on the back page IO and change
the locks then so she wasn't allowed to
come back and that was like her senior
year of high school so
uh now my sister is gone so my dad's
gone my sister's gone now I'm left with
her
um to my mom I
was what is this saying life isn't
always about butterflies and rainbow I
think that's the saying how that goes
she didn't like that I was so happy all
the time
um she wanted to keep me dumb she didn't
want to see me succeed she wanted to
keep me overweight she
wanted she she I was a child that was
never seen nor heard you wouldn't know
there was a child that even lived in our
house I wasn't allowed to have toys out
I never even owned a Barbie doll she
never I never had any of that and I'm
not trying to be like no Barbies
but like my toys were her the bank slips
from the bank and I would come and home
and play pretend and you know play with
bank slips and do whatever so I hated
hated my mom starting from a young age
but I would throw these all full um
tantrums and it used to make me so mad
because there's one picture of me that
my mom has of me standing um behind my
sister while she's doing dishes and I'm
just so mad my face is red my hands like
and I'm just so upset and so they would
always laugh at me about that and say
that I was spoiled and I threw tantrums
and all this stuff um so as I got older
living with my mom who again I didn't
know how to regulate my own emotions I
didn't know how to do that because I
wasn't allowed to have any my emot
dependent on how you how they wanted me
to be um so I was able to chameleon
easily
throughout my whole family and what I
mean by that like I my since my sister's
10 years older she was more like a
mother figure so I had to be a certain
way with her and I had to be a certain
way with my mom I had to be a certain
way with my dad and then Christina had
to figure out who she was amongst all of
them so I would have these a full
Tantrums but in but in actuality looking
back I've had mental health issues ever
since and my mom
just chocked it up to just me being a
spoiled brat and I would get punished
for it um which would then make it worse
so I started doing self Haring behavior
um in elementary school um you know
banging my head pulling my hair out
scratching myself till I bleed just all
of these things because I couldn't ever
emote and I couldn't tell her what I
needed and she didn't understand because
she wasn't a mother who was nurturing in
that regard she treated me more like a
pupil than a child
so every time I acted up like that I got
punished so she would treat me like I
was a crazed animal um when I would have
these issues she would sit me in front
of a mirror and make me watch myself um
to see how ridiculous I looked um there
was a time where she actually dragged me
down into the basement and it wasn't a
finished basement and the had one of
those pool chain lights right and I
couldn't reach it so she's like there
you're going to be in a basement like an
animal like you are right
so that's how that
was
then you know my during all this my dad
was still working and he's living with
my grandmother mother doing his own
thing and my mom I come home from work
or school one day and back then I was a
latch key kid um I went to latch key and
then as I got older I had the key and I
got to let myself in but on this
particular day my mom decided she wanted
to come home early so back then it was
like huge to have your mom home when you
got home from school I was like oh my
God I'm so excited so I ran home and I I
come in and I drop off my stuff and I go
in and we had like a living room in a
great room back then maybe they call it
living room family room but you know the
room that nobody goes in with the high
ceilings and all that [__] so we had one
of those and she's sitting on the
couch and she's making out with some
dude right and I'm just
like just shocked like okay who is this
man and why is my mom on the couch now
mind you we're upper middle class so
it's not like it's normal for me to see
my mom just making out on the couch you
know know so she's like H this is so and
so and I'm
like so that was my first encounter
with the Devil Himself he um this man
ruined my life he um I was already a
child that was never seen never heard he
made
it set in stone he pushed me out of my
mom's life push me out of the bed again
I had never slept in bed by myself I had
never taken a shower by myself so this
man comes in and then all of a sudden
you're thrown to the Wolves Christina
and I'm in elementary school so I'm
fending for myself in the night um it
was so bad that my mom had to sit in the
shower with me like in the bathroom
while I took a shower cuz I was so
terrified something was going to happen
to me because I always thought my sister
was protecting me from something like
why is she
always why is she always keeping me to
her am I saving her from something or
she saving me from
something so I was completely paranoid
all the time but you know he started
coming over more regularly and I just
didn't like him at
all and what started happening is family
night she would be like you know he's
really trying to you know have us be a
family you know why don't you come into
the you know bedroom and and watch
movies CU you know he he really wants to
spend that time so back then in the
early 90s having a VCR you know late '
80s early 90s it was a big deal we had
two VCRs in the house one in the living
room and then one in my mom's room you
would think you've spend family time
You' spend family time in the living
room but no family time was in the
bedroom
so I started going in there and watching
movies and so they would be laying up in
the front of the bed sitting up and I'd
be laying at the bottom and back then
you know they had the big wall
entertainment center unit she had in her
room so the TV was like freaking high
and so she had like this brass bed with
the high like
footboard so I'm like laying there
trying to watch this TV
and it would be late at night on school
nights
and at first it was like okay whatever
and
then there would be motion going on not
knowing what was going on I'm like
whatever whatever okay they're messing
around you know tickling I don't know
what they're doing
so he would come over ever so often
sometimes it would be movie night um
there were other times I remember the
first first time um when I was in my
room by
myself um I heard my
mom thought something was happening to
her heavy breathing moaning he's moaning
things are shaking things are knocking
they're having full-blown out sex door
open on just nobody's home type
situation and so me I don't know what
the hell's going on I'm sitting in my
room I'm shaking thinking my mom's
getting murdered in the in the room like
what do I do I'm in not fight or fle but
I'm in freeze mode about ready to
vomit and I'm crying and she sends him
into my room sweaty in his underwear
telling me what's going on there's
nothing going on here and I'm like no I
no you're not you're having a bad dream
no I'm not yeah yes you are so I lay
back down 10 minutes later I hear it up
again and so I remember at that moment I
was looking up and I'm like
either I'm crazy or they're just never
going to believe me so I just had to
take it you know so I started to realize
what was happening after I was hearing
all that kind of put two and two
together about what was going on in the
bedroom when I was in the bed watching
movies so every time I would see movies
from Blockbuster on the counter I knew
it was going to be movie
night I ended up getting smarter and
realized that the quicker I would fall
asleep the quicker they would get done
so she had this um it's like a picture
box maybe dollhouse my grandmother made
um and it was glass enclosed and so it
was underneath the entertainment center
so when I'd be laying there I could see
the reflection in the back so I could
see what they were doing um so I knew
once my mom got up and got a warm
washcloth for him that it was over and
then I could get up and I could go but I
couldn't go before that because if I
left before that they would make me come
back like I don't want to be part of the
family or two if I just didn't want to
go I'm not giving him a chance and I
don't like him um so I was kind of stuck
being this third wheel and this weird
sex Kink thing he must have had to have
some young girl in the bed with uh with
them while they had their sex up
paids so
um
that caused me to be over sexualized as
a young girl obviously I mean not
obviously but you know that's what
happens now while that's is going on at
home I'm there's my
dad um he would pick me up like every
other weekend CU you know there were
divorce visitation
and when he picked me up it was all
about shopping and going out to eat and
gifts and new clothes he hated the way
my mom dressed me because she would take
me to Kmart and put me in Kmart shoes my
mom made good money she had a Corvette
like but she dressed me like from Kmart
clothes and I got teased so bad and I
was chubby as a kid and I'm Hispanic
growing up in this rural White
America mostly blond hair blue-eyed kids
sporty um and here I am chubby I look
different I'm dark features I'm hairy um
I wasn't well-liked and so then I go
with my dad and my dad goes and buys me
Nikes and he buys me all these fancy
clothes and he buys me jewelry and we're
going out to eat all the time and we
would go to this truck
stop like right in town and um I
remember this one particular time we' go
to this truck stop and my dad would sit
there and talk to me for hours like
we're two adults he would talk to me
about life and what he wanted me to be
when I grew up you know wanted be in the
FBI he wanted me to play the saxophone
he he wanted me to be and the police
like he wanted all these things for me
and I just had to sit there
and so this one day he was like yeah
Christina you're going to be the only
one that's going to come bring me
cigarettes in prison one day and I was
like stop I was like prison's only for
bad people and he like laughed and he
was like no you're going to be the only
one that's going to come visit me in
prison and I was like whatever and you
know I just continue
coloring and so um as time went on the
these things started happening more
frequently you know and I when I got
older like in the Middle School um I
started noticing my dad was a little
different now my sister wasn't living at
home I'm younger my dad's living here my
mom's having sex in bed with her
boyfriend and we're doing all that I'm
in school having an awful time I'm
having these tantrums I'm hating life
and my dad comes over one day and he
picks me up and my sister was there and
he hands us a box
and he says take this box put it in the
trunk and take it to your aunt's house
and so I'm just standing there like what
and my dad's like don't open it don't
touch it put it in the trunk and just
drive so my sister puts it in the trunk
we close the trunk my dad leaves and so
we stand there looking at each other of
course we're going to go open the box in
the trunk right it was like this big so
she makes me open it go open it so I
open it and it's just filled with
nothing but money just rolls of money in
there I don't know why we threw it we
threw in there like it was a bomb like
oh my God they're going to know we open
this box so we drove in we drove in
Silence about a half hour to go drop
this off at my aunt's
house that's the first time
I realized that my dad was a drug
dealer and then everything started
making sense the clothing the shopping
the jewelry the trips um fifth grade he
took me on a a cruise to the
Bahamas um you know we were the stars of
the ship he had me in the casino and the
cruise ship in fifth grade I won like a
jackpot he won a jackpot we got shirts
like we're celebrities right we're up on
the top deck doing a limbo contest and
like he's giving me like the little bit
of his drink left in his cup we're
living the life you know had money
spread on the bed I ate cornish hen like
who eats cornish hen like you know what
I mean like I don't know the Cornish
hand was so I'm like okay this is cool
so as then more things went on um my mom
started to really resent me because my
dad was dressing me the way that he was
the problem with that is my dad wanted
me in the image of of his ideal woman so
he wanted me to look like somebody he
would like to look at or my mom wanted
me to look like someone that wouldn't
want to look at me that would look at
her because my mom had this whole
competition thing the thing is is she
used me for her boyfriend to get off as
per that was so freaking perverted um
yet she still wanted to keep me fat so I
became a closet eater so there's just so
much of so much just messed up stuff she
was always so jealous of my sister
because my sister was skinnier than her
um like my mom was so jealous like I
couldn't even wear her shoes because
she'd be like oh your feet are too fat
you're going to stretch them out oh you
can't eat what I do I'm so skinny you
know she was like that complete textbook
narcissist um her favorite word for me
was dense um I remember I went to school
one day and I was so proud that I knew
this big word and I was like my mom
calls me dce like it was something cool
right and she's like did you look
like oh okay and I was like yeah and she
also calls me factious right and so I
thought oh I'm using a big word this is
cool and she's like oh
okay so that was you know I was Den to
her to my dad I was like a star
pupil when we would go out to eat he
would I wasn't allowed to drink anything
he would take my cup and he would move
it to the end of the table I wasn't
allowed to
drink if he tried to give me a bite of
food and I didn't eat it he would yell
at me so I had to eat whatever it is
that he gave to me otherwise I was just
terrible and his whole day was
ruined
so we would take these trips and um he
would buy me these clothes and it got
into the point where I'm in middle
school now and I'm coming into myself
I'm a woman now um I remember when I
first um started my period my mom never
taught me how to be a woman I didn't
know anything about my body um
I learned what I learned from the kids
in the backseat of the school bus right
you hear all the big kids talking about
nasty stuff so I knew a little bit about
things but nothing outside of health
class at school so I remember the day I
started my period I I was like
devastated um and I had to call her and
tell her cuz I didn't know what to do
and she told me to go upstairs and get
like a head from underneath her sink
which is was one of those like
postpartum ones it was like like this
big so it went from like belly button to
like middle of my back right I'm so I'm
like devastated like oh my God I got to
wear this like my life is over I can't
go to school this way so she's like no
when we get home we're going to go to
the store so we get home she I get in
the car we get to the grocery store mind
you again we live in a rural Town
there's only one grocery store so you're
bound to see your teacher your
schoolmate your freaking you know
basketball coach whatever at the grocery
store so we get there she hands me a $10
bill and she's like okay here you go
like what like I didn't even know what
to do in there I don't even know what I
was buying so I literally ran in there
and I went down the aisle because I
remember everything is pink in the
feminine product aisle so I went there
and I saw the first pink like bag and I
like tucked it and I hauled ass to the
to the register and I like put it on the
conveyor and I like walked with it cuz
how terrifying and how embarrassing
would that be
by myself your mom doesn't go with you
so I get home and here is this pervert
boyfriend of hers banging pots and
celebrating telling me welcome to
Womanhood oh was so happy you're so
excited like celebrating like it's some
tribal right of passage I was like if I
always wasn't feeling mortified enough I
got this guy celebrating it and my mom's
like laughing and thinking it's
hilarious like how
so that was my experience with that
luckily my dad had been dating a woman
my stepmom who was the most
absolutely beautiful
amazingly sweet she was a mother that
every girl
deserves
and without her I wouldn't have never
learned how to be a woman I wouldn't
have probably learned how to be a good
person um not saying I'm not but you
know when you have two people in your
life who are just so bad and so toxic
you usually pick up from that
environment and I always looked for her
looked at her as my Saving Grace um so
she taught me about Womanhood she taught
me to to be confident with my body she
you know the first time I met her um my
dad took me over to her house and she
sat me
down and she braided my hair and um
my mom never never even braided my
hair and it's something so small but it
was something like so meaningful for a
little
girl so we sat there for
hours and she she cared about what I
cared about she wanted to know what my
favorite show was and what I like to do
for fun it wasn't critical it
wasn't judgy
she cared about me as as a little girl
and she let me be a little girl but she
also helped me be a
woman and
um thank you she helped me be a woman
and I'm just so forever grateful that I
had her in my
life
so her and my dad got
married and um well that's later on
that's why let me back up a little bit
back home with my mom um and when I got
into Middle School I really started
getting into
boys and um started drinking and I
started
smoking and um sneaking out of the house
I snuck out for my 14th birthday and um
I got caught I went to snuck out with my
boyfriend we went skinny dipping and um
got drunk and we were supposed to be
back home before the sun came up
but that didn't happen my boyfriend's
brother didn't want to take us back home
so we had to walk and the police got
called and my dad came home or came to
my mom's house that day and realized I
was with a boy and that was the first
time he actually beat me
up he started calling me a whor and
started like punching me in the head
and doing all that kind of stuff
um so once I I started getting into boys
and started having sex um that was kind
of it for me as far as Behavior wise and
schoolwise I um didn't care about school
I had friends um I wasn't a nerd I
wasn't popular but
I I had a good group of
friends
um but I started sneaking out and I my
mom started not liking me and uh we
stopped really talking and at that point
I moved in with my
dad um although I couldn't live with him
because my stepmom um she had three
children of her own there was no room
for me there in their house so my dad
made me move and live with my
grandmother um who was an invain she was
an ampute had diabetes and so I lived
with her um and that was very difficult
because I'm still a kid myself I don't
know anything about taking care of a
sickly
grandmother
um so when I was there I started dating
older
guys and I didn't see anything wrong
with that you know but just what it is
what it was and so I would sneak out of
my grandmother's
house
um my dad and I got into another awful
fight he broke into my room at my
grandmother's house and for what forever
reason that day he was just really
shitty mood and grabbed me by the back
of the hair and just threw me down on
the floor and just started beating me
calling me disgusting and a pig and just
all this stuff and I didn't know
why and um I remember my my mom was
coming to pick me up for visitation you
know it was her weekend at the time my
mom had been
um going through chemo she had stage
four breast
cancer and so it was her weekend for for
for me and it was my birthday and I
remember I ran out through the front
yard Barefoot just screaming telling her
to take me to the hospital like dad just
beat me up and she's like you don't want
to do that you don't want to do that you
know you don't want your dad to go to go
to jail and so she just completely just
ignored that whole fact it was similar
like when my sister was in high school
and my mom would beat her up all the
time one of her friends um called or
told the school counselor my sister was
getting beat up she had a fat lip and
all that and the CPS came to the house
and my mom told me go upstairs don't say
anything don't come out um if somebody
comes to talk to you one or two word or
answers don't say anything so I had to
stay up in my room while she was talking
to the CPS person and um was saying that
you know my sister's getting beat up by
her boyfriend that abuse was from him
like you know crazy teenager all this
stuff
so kind of similar situation ation and
um so throughout my teen years I was
going back and forth between my mom and
my dad's house and we moved out of the
house in Heartland uh the one that they
had built and my mom was building
another house and we moved into an
apartment in between that till the house
was getting built and um I had taken a
bunch of pills it was my first attempt
at I committing suicide so I thought I
didn't know anything about taking pills
and I saw on the the top of the
refrigerator there was a a bunch of pill
bottles so I was like a I'll just take
them right
so when my mom called to find out you
know what would happen if I took them
all she let me just stay home and throw
up because I ended up taking
antibiotics like what is so she was like
yeah no you're just going to stay home
and throw that up and so that's what I
did and um when we moved into this new
house and we moved away this was my
freshman year of high school tough time
for any kid especially to move to a new
school you know freshman year and when I
moved to this new town I really started
getting into drugs um you know different
types of kids different types of drugs
you know like acid was big then you know
doing whippets know was a big thing back
then um and so I hated the school I went
to I didn't fit in and it was summertime
and my mom my grandmother's house I was
going to go back there however I got
raided so it was pretty much confirmed
at that point that my dad was a drug
dealer um my grandmother's house was
raided my uncle by marriage was actually
living there at the time that's why I
couldn't live there right away and when
they raided it my dad had to I guess
there was a tip something happened I
don't know the ray oh the guy went out
and went for a jog and got tipped off my
Dad ran to the house grabbed these two
bags of weed that they had I didn't know
about it threw it in the neighbor's yard
so when the police came they wouldn't
know they just threw it like it's trash
they found like $300,000 shoved up in
the fireplace at my grandmother's
house I'm living I I'm visiting here on
the weekends I had no idea this poor
woman my poor old grandmother was there
when they came in and raided the house
they took all the tiles and [__] out of
the ceiling everything so he goes to
prison and my dad essentially takes over
he's like the bookie the the numbers guy
he wasn't really doing too much of
the the picking up and dropping off
however you know looking back when my
dad used to pick me up on the
weekends we would go
um I'm not say make drops but my dad
would make these stops we would go to
bars we'd go here we'd go there and he'd
do whatever he was was doing I wasn't
allowed to ask I wasn't allowed to look
I wasn't allowed like if my dad were to
look in this direction and I would to go
like this I wasn't allowed like he'd
smack me um I couldn't ask anything and
when we would go to a restaurant I had
to sit
um with my back to the door he had to
sit facing the door I couldn't walk in
front of him I couldn't walk behind him
I had to walk right next to him
um but
um I forgot I was saying anyway
um he would take me shopping when I was
getting
older
um he was so particular about the way
that I dressed and the way that I looked
I remember he used to make my stepmom
take me to go get my makeup
done even to this day when I put
lipstick on my dad used to always hate
the way that I would put my lipstick on
and make me take it off and that's why
he would make her go take me to get it
professionally done so I knew how to do
it cuz he didn't want me to walk around
looking
ridiculous
so he would take me to the salon and get
my hair
done when he got really big into the
whole drug thing um
he became part of a Puerto Rican Social
Club they called it AKA a
501c drug front money washing type
situation where they would my dad would
host these elaborate um
dances on the weekends and um he would
bring in salsa bands and all this stuff
and it was like the Highlight you know
the community it was huge Puerto Rican
Community back then that came up to
Pontiac cuz that's where the family was
from and you know General Motors and all
that was there so um here I am young
girl in these parties these elaborate
adult parties um Untouchable in this
place I'm in here I'm dancing with my
dad um he's teaching me how to dance and
there's grown men in here and I'm
dressed up hair done I'm like 11 years
old with all these grown men and you
know him making me get special outfits
for these occasions and I'm hanging out
till 1 2 o'clock in the morning drinking
alcohol you know at these places but
that was fun for me you know shopping
spree in New York that was fun um all of
the all of the spoiling that was that
was fun but it came at a price I had to
be what he needed me to be because I
learned at a young
age that if I act the way he wants me to
I'll be okay okay if I act the way that
I want to with my mom I'm going be okay
my sister she was off doing her thing
she was like a mom to me I could never
be myself with her um so she never
really even knew
me um so after the raid and after all
that I moved back home
um I attempted the suicide I moved to
this new school I moved with my
grandmother I came back home to live
with my mom she sent me to this
alternative school
worst idea because I got so involved in
drugs and
alcohol it was really
bad and um I started just sleeping with
with any guy I didn't care older men
married men guys that I met at the
grocery store there I just it wasn't a
big deal and then I met my boyfriend my
teenage boyfriend and his mother was an
addict and I had a car my dad bought me
a car and so I would go up to see him he
lived in Flint which was at the time
like 30 minutes away from where I lived
and he was 15 I was 16 and um his mom
left him just she was a crack addict and
left him 15 years old in this house no
running water no electricity no nothing
um at the time I'm still having problems
with my own mother it got to the point
um
where I wanted to almost kill her
boyfriend honestly
so I came home from school one day and
my friend she thought she was pregnant
and took a pregnancy test and I hid the
box under my bed and he went into my
room and searched my room and found it
so when I got home they confronted me my
boyfriend at the time was black so she
called me or he called me the n-word
loving [__] all you do is suck and word
dicks in the backseat of the car you
just he's going in on me just with
atrocious things and and I look at my
mom and I literally I'm like are you
going to let him sit there and talk to
me like that and she's like yeah because
he's not
lying I'm like what the [__] so I call
my dad and I'm like Dad you need I'm
going to kill him I had to lock myself
up in the laundry room because I was so
mad I was afraid I was going to hurt
this man luckily well not luckily my
stepmom worked for the police department
not in our town different town but she
called the police on my mom uh for
emotional abuse and so my Mom hated my
stepmom that was the whole rival rivalry
there but um after that I moved with my
boyfriend up in Flint and we were both
homeless you know my mom she ended up
locking the door on me similar than what
she did my sister I came home late
curfew she locked the door I wasn't
going to sit there and bang on the door
and beg her to let me in I'm like fine
you don't want me here then I'm not
going to be here so I went and lived
with
him we lived on the floor in his mother
and her boyfriend's house or partment
she he had found his mom living with
another addict um and we slept on the
floor there and then him and my my
boyfriend and her boyfriend got into a
knife fight terrible
so now we're we're homeless we're living
in a park in
Flint 15 16y old we'd have to go to the
soup kitchen to
eat um so we decided we're going to go
to Jobe so we go to Job Corp in Grand
Rapids and that was a culture shock I
was the only white girl in there with
all black girls and I'm sharing a room
with with five other black girls and I
think the only reason why I got lucky is
because my boyfriend was black so I was
like cool and plus I was like half pan
so it was like you know I was accepted
and I made a lot of friends and going
there actually was the best thing that
could have happened because when I got
out I
um wanted to do something with my life I
wanted to you know be something
important and when I got home my
grandmother died and I moved in with my
dad cuz I knew he was going to be
devastated and but I got a good job I
started working I broke up with the
boyfriend and flint
and I met my
ex-husband who was my
aunt's best friend
son and we met at work and he would come
up there all the time
and I had gotten
pregnant and we moved so we moved out
together I got pregnant short shortly
after and I'm 19 now and um I was the
happiest that I could possibly have been
after the initial shock and I remember
so scared having to tell my dad that I
was pregnant because I feel like it was
he would think I was like betraying them
in a weird way we almost had this like
weird relationship where we weren't a
couple but it was
like I don't know it was weird like that
like when we would go out in public I
had to hold my dad's hand like had to
either hold his hand or arm and arm like
sometimes people would think we were
together like it was just weird like
that but so I was terrified to tell him
so when I called to tell him I was like
hi Dad I'm pregnant I'm getting married
it was like one sentence cuz I was like
then it would be better you know so we
had a shotgun wedding and um I was four
months pregnant and my dad sent us uh to
Vegas for a week on our
honeymoon pregnant but it was whatever I
couldn't even gamble it or anything but
you know it was a week it was nice and I
was the happiest that I had ever been in
my life we moved into this really cute
town home um you know we got my son's
Nursery
ready I had never in my life life felt
happiness before I found finally found
my purpose I was a wife and I was a
mother and I loved being pregnant and I
loved my
husband and and um he was born and it
was beautiful and
um things started falling apart with my
husband and I and it was
devastating and he left uh one month
before Dominic turned a year
old he and I'll never forget it when he
walked out the
door he said I never loved you I only
married you because I knocked you up
and I I think that moment my whole
soul everything in me just fell out you
know because I here I am living
my what I thought I was supposed to
be and now it's gone and once my
ex-husband left
me I just went off the deep end I
started drinking I started going to the
clubs I started doing all sorts of drugs
I didn't care I did not care at that
point
um I remember he came to drop my son off
and he had another woman in the car and
I was so devastated that my son was in a
car with another
woman that I was so mad at him like I
literally like ripped like I ripped my
shirt and I like threw our wedding
picture because it's time before that
like we were trying to make our marriage
work like we got a divorce and we walked
out of the courthouse together he was
like we're going to we're going to do it
the right way he enlisted in the Army
he's like you know we're going to do
things the right way I'm going to marry
you the right way I'm going to do good
by you and our son and so I believed him
and he went into the army and he came
home from leave and we were supposed to
do all these family things together and
he met a woman and married her a couple
months later and I didn't even know I
didn't even know I'm thinking we're
working on our marriage and rebuilding
it and he goes and gets married and I
was again devastated
so I went through this whole club drug
thing for about two
years
um he ends up marrying again and having
a child and I couldn't have any more
children um at that point but
um I got so involved heavily in drugs
that I was a terrible mother and and I
never thought that I would ever be a
terrible mom I started dropping him off
to whoever would watch him I was lying
to my dad telling him that I was going
to college and wasn't two three nights a
week I would tell him I'm at school and
I just didn't go I was at the bar I was
at the club three four five times a week
and um I was just in a in a blur and it
got to the point where when my son was
three I'm like I can't do it anymore I'm
an awful human being and I'm an awful
mom so we picked up and we moved and I
moved um half hour away from everything
I got clean I you know got my son into
t-ball like I was doing like little like
I had a grown-up job now I've got my
first car like I'm just I'm doing well
my mental health um I probably should
have said that you know I
I when I was 15 after the first suicide
attempt I had an I had another incident
where I was doing self harm so I was a
self harer I didn't even talk about my
mental illness but yeah I was self harer
and my mom I ended up going an impatient
hospital for like 3
weeks um because I was cutting myself so
she put me in the hospital so I had been
battling on and off with my mental
health undiagnosed for many years even
throughout my divorce um when I moved
away from all the drugs and stuff I got
better um I thought things were going
well um um things with my dad were still
weird he would since I moved far away he
wanted me to like hold on to his car he
wanted to park his car at my house he
wanted me to hold on to a briefcase I
remember going over his house and he was
like take this briefcase I want you to
take it to your house I want you hide it
don't touch it he gave me the ACC
combination to it he was like don't
touch it unless you need to touch it and
you'll know when you need to touch it I
was like okay whatever so I go home and
I hide the briefcase and that was like a
running joke with us and my sister for a
long time the briefcase but
um then I moved back back home and I
started dating a
guy and this particular guy I was with
for almost 20 years and he was um very
toxic very
narcissistic and I did whatever I could
do to please this individual because
everybody else I didn't want him to
leave like my husband left me
it hurts so bad that I just never wanted
to feel that pain
again so I moved back and and we started
dating and I was still working and I
stopped drinking stopped doing drugs I
stopped smoking cigarettes like I was
All-American good Mom now my son was in
elementary school and
um my boyfriend and I he would be
horrible to me and I remember you know I
was telling my girlfriend um just last
night that he used this analogy with me
one time he was
like he's like do you know how pan he's
like you know pancakes and syrup right
he's like what happens when you put too
much syrup on your pancakes they get
soggy and he was like yeah too much of
you makes me soggy it's too much so I
don't I don't want that much and you
know the other analogy he used was being
with me was like shoveling S no I don't
like it I don't want to do it but I have
to do it it needs to get done so
that's that was in response to me saying
hey I haven't seen you in a month can I
see you or hey I haven't heard your
voice in three weeks you know can we
talk on the phone
so I was too needy to him and so I was
always constantly chasing chasing
that um so fast forward now I'm still
dating him is
2009 and 2009 my Dad decided he wants to
buy my son and I a house and I was great
I'm like okay I knew where the money was
coming from
so I didn't want to live in the town he
wanted me to live in I didn't want to
live in the house he wanted me to live
in the house he wanted to buy me was
literally across the street from his in
the corner he had bought his house for
cash and wanted to buy the house across
the street and I'm like no I don't want
to live that close to my dad so I was
Finding other houses in the area that I
wanted so on this particular day um I
went to go pick up my son he was sick my
dad had just watched him in his house
the day before um and this particular
day my ex-husband mom mom was watching
him so we met up and I had called my dad
earlier this morning like hey did you go
check out this house I told you to go
look at for me and he was like no no
I'll do it I'll do it I'll do it I'm
like okay so I left him alone and I
picked up my son and I called my dad to
be like hey did you go look at it and he
didn't answer so I was near his house so
I was like okay I'll just swing over
there and there was a bunch of cars
there so I was like okay that's probably
why he's not answering so he probably
got the guys over there probably you
know the Puerto Ricans the guys get
together they like make Pig and you know
they do all kinds of cooking and stuff
so that's what I thought it was and so I
rounded the corner and I went back to
the main street and as soon as I rounded
that corner my stepmom calls and she's
like hey are you driving and I'm like
yeah she's like I need for you to pull
over and I'm like why she's like just
pull over I'm like you know like how you
seen the movies no why we were doing all
that and she's like I just need for you
to pull over so I was like fine so I
pull over in in the the grocery store
parking lot and she's like is is Dominic
with you my son I'm like yeah he's
sleeping in the back seat and um she's
like your dad was arrested he's here
um at the police station and I just
remember like I literally fell like I
literally fell on the ground and like I
like it wasn't real like she was talking
to me and like I couldn't so she was
like I need for you to go find your aunt
I need for you to go get a lawyer I need
for you to do all this stuff and so I'm
just like I'm I think
20 six at this time I knew nothing about
any of this I didn't even know where my
aunt was I'm driving around driving
around driving around and I remember you
know she called me back and I was like I
don't know where she is like I can't
find her she didn't answering the phone
and so my dad was communicating through
her and was like hey you need to go
check this place out so I went over
there and I found her and the only
reason why I found her is because I
could hear her talking Spanish loud with
my other cousins and I remember opening
the door and I was like like I couldn't
even speak I couldn't even get it out
and they're like what what what my dad
was arrested and so my aunt she had been
through this before because her
ex-husband has been to prison many times
for drugs she just was like pulled up
the phone book and was like you know
casually flipping through it to find a
lawyer my cousin's over here about to
have a heart attack on the floor I'm
freaking out Dominic's in the car
sleeping I'm just like this so we get to
the house because we had to go to my
dad's
house oh I forgot to say before even I
went to go find my aunt when I found out
my dad was arrested I went back around
to his house I played dumb like I didn't
know what was going on I was like oh
pulled up like I'm just going to go see
my dad
like and so this FBI agent was walking
by and he had a photo and I was like
what are you doing my photo like all
irritated and I was like I want to go
see my dad I want to go see my dad and
they were like oh he's fine you know you
can go in in a minute knowing that my
dad isn't in there and they're like yeah
you know we're almost done there's dogs
there's all this there's a there's a
tractor trailer Tru sitting out front
I'm like what the [__] is going on in
here so when they all left I walked
inside and the person living with my dad
who had been arrested before who was
part of the raid at my grandmother's
house many years prior he was there um
andan he was living with my dad and
there was two Mexican gentlemen sitting
on the couch
and I walk in and I was like like what
the [__] going on so the two guys I'm
like they need to go get out of my house
like I'm telling these you guys get out
of here and I'm telling this other
individual that was living my dad get
out of here and the
house was raided um luckily they didn't
like destroy everything
um the police officers literally had a
pizza party there there was plates and
[__] and pizza boxes and everywhere red
cups um so I I surveyed I I looked
around and I went to the basement and I
remember a couple weeks prior to this
you know I went down there my dad likes
to sleep down in the basement in the
summer cuz it's hot and
um he I I said what are you doing all
this construction for he's like oh I'm
just building a bedroom down here and I
was like well what do you need another
fuse box for like why you need two fuse
boxes he's like oh I'm building a bar
only my dad doesn't drink why you're
building a bar so whatever so I go
downstairs after the raid and they
kicked in the door to this
room inside there's this whole operation
about to to be constructed there was
filtration systems lighting pots dirt
soil all kinds of [__] he was going to
make a growroom down there in the
basement and that's what the extra fuse
box was for he was going to run power
from the pole straight into the house
and I'm was like are you [__] kidding
me my son you I started getting angry at
this point you know I'm like stressed
out but I'm not I'm angry at this point
so
we got a hold of a lawyer next day
shitty ass lawyer Shady you know my
sister and I she was living in Florida
so I was basically handling it all by
myself I was hoping that my dad had
money buried somewhere for situations
like this like in the movies like do you
have something somewhere for us and he
didn't so I had to start liquidating
assets my dad owned RAC sources what
happened in the
briefcase so the briefcase he to get
back the briefcase actually had his will
in
it so at the time he gave it to me he
was I think worried that something was
going to happen to him um and you know
it's funny that you bring that up back
when I was living with my grandmother's
house I remember this time that my dad
came and he came to my room and he
handed me a
38 he was like I need for you to take
this and put it in your closet and do
not touch it don't touch it until I ask
for it back so so I'm I'm holding on to
my dad's gun right not knowing if he
just killed somebody you know years
later he's giving me his briefcase you
know he he had me sometimes go into the
bank putting deposits and stuff bringing
out money orders doing that for him so
he's involving me in these things
without me knowing I'm involved but
knowing I don't know was this weird
thing it's like I knew he knew I knew
and I knew like but we just never SP
okay I I benefited from it
so I had to liquidate his horses I grew
up at the racetrack which is kind of
cool we would go to the racetrack all
the time I was able to go back with the
owners and go to the horses like it was
a big deal but anyway he had two horses
I had to sell those I had to go start
collecting money from people that owed
him money and when we went to the
lawyers we went with a a McDonald's bag
of cash and we like handed it to them it
was so
embarrassing um my dad had a safe they
gotten in the safe like I had to move
the safe to another
location
um the charges so what happened was my
dad was set up by a confidential
informant what drugs was he was he
selling
cocaine so he was set up by a
confidential informant um there was a
big shipment of cocaine that came to my
dad's house that's what the tractor
trailer was in front of his house it
came up with a shipment of furniture but
there was also cocaine there and the
shipment came to my dad's house they
they were processing it breaking it up
taking it to where it needs to go there
were several people at the house there
was money counters heat sealers scales
all of that there in the house um this
individual was calling my dad calling my
dad wanted wanted 2 kilos of
cocaine and so the shipment came my dad
took the two kilos put it in like
birthday gift bag went into the bar
handed off the gifts as my dad came out
they surrounded
him um it took him back to the house and
it's so terrible my dad was so scared
that they he [__] his pants and they
made him sit in it the entire time he
was at his house um questioning him and
my dad signed a confession he confessed
um of whatever what everything that
happened and in that raid They
confiscated
$825,000 in a hidden floorboard of that
tractor
trailer um the police officers decided
to take a pizza have a pizza party with
some of that money um and they took my
dad's pocket
money uh
so my life at that point I had to I had
a nice little condo my son and I were so
happy again and so happy finally like
doing good I taught him how to ride his
bike his school was down the street we
lived by a park things were great boom
my dad's arrested his whole life dumps
in my lap I had to leave my house I had
to move into his house I had to get rid
of all of my stuff so now I'm living in
his house all of his stuff I'm now in
charge
of his financials his legal stuff he had
a legal case in in local he had a legal
case in Detroit I was visiting him in
the prison I had to quit my job to help
on his case because we couldn't afford
the the money for the
lawyer on top of that I'm freaking
paranoid because these people in Mexico
didn't get their money they didn't get
their drugs and they didn't get their
money they didn't get anything so now
they know where we live they know where
I live they know they didn't get their
[__] so my aunt and I had to take this
little piece of paper newspaper clipping
to some prison way up North in Michigan
and drop it off at some prison to
somebody I don't know who I didn't ask
to let them know like hey I didn't keep
the money it was taken by the police so
I lived in complete paranoia for a while
my dad started sending people to the
house to check on me I had to tell them
look stop sending people here like it's
scary we had to like get rid of all the
weed growing stuff I had to sell all
that
um my dad's you know didn't go to trial
um because he ultimately pled guilty and
he pled guilty because he was having
somebody testify against him who got
arrested after him my dad's right-hand
man the one he was sending over to the
house all the time to check on me was
going to flip on him so my dad had to
plead guilty my dad was 60 years old
when he got arrested and he was
sentenced to 13 years in
prison um his charges uh were for the
two kilos of cocaine he also had cocaine
in the house recreationally and then he
also had two firearms and so they got
him with felony Firearms too um so
minimum sentence was 13 years maximum
was
and my life crumbled
again and um I had to be a support
system for him and it's interesting
because just the other day I found a
letter that I wrote to him and I don't
know if I sent him a copy or not
but just saying you know you got this
dad you know I'm I got your back it's
going to be okay I'm going to take care
of everything for you meanwhile um my ex
moved in with me he's constantly
cheating on me I'm hanging on to him cuz
he's my only support system my mother
doesn't speak to me anymore um because
you know I had finally started getting
good therapy I started getting on
medication and she just kept asking me
do you talk about me through therapy do
you talk about about me I know you're
talking about me do you tell them what
an awful childhood you had and so I
would tell her I'm like I don't sit
there in therapy and talk about you all
the time right so finally she drove me
nuts so much I was like yeah I do talk I
do say things I told them about this the
perverted stuff that you had him do I
talk about how you had this grown man
shaving my legs I told him that you had
this grown man throwing a party cuz I
started my period and you this grown man
who wanted me to be a bikini model for
his classic cars and he would tell me he
wanted to watch porn with me to teach me
the real way of having sex like I mom
used to send me into the bathroom to him
every morning to do a twirl for him so
he could see what I was wearing and he
would like you know do the oh you got
something on you and he'd like cop a
feel like do all that [__] so my mom
started saying um you know after that
conversation I told her I was like
please just take my side for once just
please please don't run and tell him let
let me and you handle this so two days
later she calls me back and she's like
I'm not ever going to be considered or
be um associated with being a sexual
deviant and she kept saying sexual
deviant I'm like I never said that like
I still loved you I've loved you all
these years I'm still your daughter I've
looked past all of
this that happened then I'm just working
through it now I'm getting medication
you know I'm finally taking care of
myself and she's like yeah no I'm I'm
not gonna be a sexual deviant you're not
gonna you know consider me that she's
like I no longer want to have a
relationship with you I'm like what
she's like I don't I don't want you in
my life anymore and I was like okay I
said well you know that you're forgoing
your relationship with your grandson too
and she's like yeah I know I was like
okay um you're going to die a lonely
woman and that's the last time I spoke
to her and that was in
2013 so I went through most of that
stuff with my dad and then I had my ex
who was constantly cheating was toxic
emotionally abusive when I was with him
my self harming was really bad
because I just wanted him to love me and
he wouldn't I threw myself in traffic I
cut my arm ended up getting stitches I
broke my hand I had stitches in my hand
I um I wanted to die all the time I just
just I just wanted to die everything was
everything that good was good was bad my
dad was my
everything I didn't know how to take
care of a home I didn't know how to do
any of that stuff he did all that for me
so now I'm relying on this man who
just he treated me like
trash and we were supposed to get
married and he I found out he cheated on
me like um two months before our wedding
we were going to get married here um La
Hoya and uh had my dress and I had
everything only thing I didn't have was
my flowers and
cake and he cheated and I took my son
and my stepmom on a cruise the bahas
instead with the money I spent on the
wedding but I took him
back
um my sister didn't help me with my dad
when he was
arrested she was very distant and stayed
in
Florida I moved out of my dad's house um
2015 after he sent me a letter telling
me I betrayed him and that I stole from
him when I my dad left me managing his
money while he went to prison and he was
getting his pension and
um I was saving that and I didn't have
to pay for rent or anything cuz this
house was paid for and and I was later
diagnosed with bipolar 2 disorder P PST
PTSD and so my bipolar
disorder um is spending money that's my
thing I spend money when I feel like
[__] that's what makes me happy and so I
took my son on vacation I took my ex and
I on vacations I never bought bags and P
you know none of that I didn't buy
extravagant things my thing is I wanted
to go on vacation because it made me
feel good it made me leave my life real
life I thought going on vacation was the
only time my ex and I were happy
together so I felt like that's the only
time Dominic my son was happy is that I
was taking them on vacations so that's
what I did and
um my sister the whole time was going
behind my back with my
dad and um got the the power of attorney
away from me I had to deed the house
back over to my
sister and I I had to move out of his
house and
um I hadn't talked to him since
2015 and um he got released in prison
in
2020 at
72 and he never reached out
um after that but during the time we
didn't speak he he kept in contact with
Dominic but never wanted to talk to me
you know he'd be talking to Dominic
right next to me and never wanted to
speak with me and it was so sad
because I had he was my everything and I
was his everything for so long and his
whole sole reason for going to prison
was greed and money and it was so much
more important to him than a
relationship with me
my mom and her
boyfriend their relationship was so much
more important than me and my
ex-husband and him being with other
women or what he was doing was so much
more important than
me and I'm not trying to be like poor me
poor me but it's like at what point does
Christina you know
anyway so
he got out in um
2020 and just recently this past
April I was in sanan
Capistrano impatient mental health home
here CU I still am battling with my my
bipolar disorder and depression and you
know I've been on medication so
but still I have issues here and there
and um while I was there my sister sends
me an email hey bad news they found Dad
Dad dead in his
bathroom I don't know anything else at
this point and so that was like the
worst
thing because I knew that my dad never
wanted to die
alone and he was really sick and she
never told me and if I would have known
he was that sick I don't care how much
he would have hated me I would have been
there I would have been in his house I
would have like banged on the door I
would have been there to take care of
him but I wasn't and so he laid there
dead on his floor in the bathroom for 3
days so that kills me that's like
riddles me with
guilt because if I wouldn't
have had not had mental illness if I
wouldn't have taken vacations and if I
wouldn't have been with this my ex piece
of [__]
boyfriend then I wouldn't have spent his
money that he would have I still would
have been in his
life I made all these bad
choices I made my mom not want me and my
dad not want me and because of that he
died
alone why why do you think your father
was so angry at you because I used his
money because I told him that he had
more money than what he did
um and he found out I was going to
replace it when he was in prison when he
was in prison I had time to do that but
my sister went behind my back and got
access got the power of attorney and
went into his bank account and told
him what I had and Stu of standing up
with me and you spent the money on on
trips and vacations and and doing things
to the house I sent her money when she
was down and out and broke spent money
sending my kid to orchestra concert in
Florida like it wasn't just random stuff
but to him I betrayed him because I
lied
so it's still fresh and I'm still trying
to like work through
it and I'm trying you know I thought it
would bring my sister and I closer my
sister and I hadn't talked since 2015
either
because at that
time when she went behind my back she
betrayed me too
like you're supposed to be my sister
you're supposed to be on my side when I
when my mom stopped talking to me she
wasn't on my side she could have stood
up with me and she didn't want to get
involved okay fine she went behind my
back and got my dad's house and did all
that she's my big sister she didn't help
me but then she went behind my
back so I did the best thing I could do
and stayed away from the family I didn't
want her to be in the middle of you know
hey Mom said this hey Dad said this or
her having to run to them and give them
information her being stressed out if
you know not being able to have me over
for Thanksgiving because mom was going
to be there like it was just messy and I
know me being around them would have
been stressful and so there's so much
going on and I told my sister I'm like
hey I need a break from all this and too
my
sister she wasn't a happy person when
her and I would be around each other
after a couple days she'd literally want
to physically fight me like she would
get so mad at me all the time I was dumb
to her you know she was so smart she was
the smart one and I was the dumb one and
I didn't do good in school and she
always got honors and she was so smart
and she did so
well and so I was treated like I was
Dumb and
um so I let her have my mom and dad she
didn't have them I was their favorite
she got beat up and all that all the
time so I figured it's her time I'll
just step back I'm a piece of [__]
daughter anyway let you and let your
kids have the parents because they had
my son I we were their favorites and so
I did feel bad that they weren't close
with her and her kids but I missed out
on my nieces and nephews too and I
regret that I didn't get to see them
grow up and so I hope by doing
this they'll know why you know why I
made the decisions and the choices that
I
did
but when I moved on to my dad's house my
ex and I got into a big altercation
he we got into a fight and he handed me
you know I was telling him I wanted to
die and he handed me a rope and he said
go ahead and do it and get it over
with and I said you know if you hate me
so much and and you don't love me then
go in there and tell Dominic that how
much you hate me how much you don't love
me I was trying to like call us Bluff so
he walked into my son's room and said
hey your mom's crazy [__] I hate her
and I don't love
her and
um that was kind of the end of the end
with that he
um he was mocking me making fun of
me he was drinking out of a bottle of
juice and he was like I'm Christina I'm
a baby so I smacked the bottle out of
his
hand and he just charged me and like
headbutted me in the
face and Dominic had to call
911 and they wouldn't take him to the
they wouldn't arrest him because he he
was smart he ran out to the police
before me and told him told them that I
had mental health issues and that I
hadn't taken my meds and I smacked him
in the face and you know he doesn't want
to press charges on me so when they came
in the house the police were already in
their mind this is bad [__] crazy [__]
and she just is having one of her
episodes and I said no he hurt me and
they're like well here's the number to
Domestic Violence Shelter I can't make
him leave you can't leave cuz you're
both on the lease so he ended up having
to live in my basement he lived in the
basement for a year of that house he
would not leave that we lived like that
and when he left
finally after sabotaging me getting at
my own place I was going to secretly
leave with my son and he sabotaged that
and ruined that chance when he
left I went off the deep end and I had
like a a breakdown and I lost everything
I lost my job I lost my car got
repossessed I couldn't pay my rent and
we got evicted and I begged the judge to
let me at least live in the house until
after my son graduates high school and
so he evicted us the day after my son
graduated so we had his graduation and
his graduation party on the same day and
the next day we I were evicted from our
home and we were homeless
and um luckily he had a friend who
parents were doing like um a flip house
and we got to stay in this house for a
little while until we got back on our
feet my son was working 40 hours a week
um his senior year of high school to
help pay bills because my mental health
was bad I couldn't hold a a full-time
job so I was working a part-time job and
part of my my issues with my with my
mental health is you know I've had 17
jobs in 13 years I can't hold a
job
um I go into the hospital out patient
you know partial day Hospital several
times a year um this time when I went
into impatient I thought well maybe this
will do it this will do the trick I need
like hardcore treatment so I've been
doing
better um we got a little townhouse and
things were looking up and up and then
my son decided to leave and and move out
and I was devastated again now my son's
gone now my ex and I were still together
still messing around he hates me I hate
him but we're still in this codependent
thing and um now I literally want to die
I'm not a mother I'm not a girlfriend
I'm not a wife I'm not a sister I'm not
a
daughter I'm not an
aunt I have no
identity I don't have I have nothing I
am utterly alone and left with myself
who I don't know who she is I had no
idea who Christina was anymore because I
spent my whole life playing for you know
being a chameleon with for all these
people though I didn't know who I was
and so being having motherhood
technically taken away I thought my
identity was completely
gone
so I changed
careers
and I start making okay
money I um broke up with my ex I mean I
don't know if it broke up but realized
that he um he was he has another he had
another woman and um it just it was just
I was tired
of being next to someone being alone you
know there nothing worse than you just
being alone but then being next to
someone and feeling
alone wasting so much of my life on
someone who just didn't love me who
probably had a whole family or fiance I
was probably the side
chick um so I decided to just pick up
and move and start my life over I was
working remotely Dominic was gone so I
was like well what's holding me here I'm
not talking to anyone
anyway so I moved I picked up and I
moved 3 hours to the other side of the
state um to essentially start over
um I guess to ReDiscover myself is like
corny you know they always say in movies
and stuff but literally that's what I
did I had to leave behind the being
known in the community as the drug
dealer's
daughter everybody that knew me there
how's your dad like like it was it was
sensationalized you know my dad was I
had people oh how's your dad oh your dad
was this your dad was that and oh
I didn't want to be
associated with the drunk Club Christina
the the the sexy like I had a guy every
week Christina I didn't want to be the
the crazy mental health is issues
terrible
daughter I didn't want any of that
anymore and I didn't tell anybody where
I was going and I changed my phone
number I didn't even tell my ex I just
left and um I moved away
and I started over and I thought that
things were going to be good like it
would just be great but the problem is
you can move yourself to another
location but it doesn't change anything
like you still have to do the
work and so that's what I've been slowly
trying to do and I did have a fallof
with some mental health stuff um but I'm
seeing a phenomenal therapist who's
amazing and I met
a really good friend who is like a
sister to
me who has my back and I haven't had
that because all the other friends that
I've had have just
liked that other side of Christina that
just isn't me
anymore
so now I'm here in
California never thought I'd be doing
this and maybe hopefully one day be able
to do a book
do do you see that the the lack of
unconditional love in your childhood
kind of set
the cuz that's all I want like that's
all I've wanted it's like
why why can't I get the love back that
I'm giving out I've overlooked your
issues and your issues and I've loved
you despite all the bad thing that
you've
done but why can't anyone love me
despite the bad things that I've
done so I I must be that bad of a person
so in my mind I must be that bad that
I'm unlovable that my love is
conditional my I don't love people
conditionally it's not this or that if
that or this no I love is love and so
you think about how can a parent just
never talk to their
child my mom hasn't spoken to me in 10
years I could never have my child out
there and not know if he's alive or
dead the concept of that blows my mind
my father who I was his
everything I did everything for him died
alone he had a
will I knew he had a will cuz it was in
his briefcase I knew it was in the will
my sister said you know after he died um
you know Dad left a handwritten letter
and I'll have to find it you know he so
I'm like okay couple months later she's
like you know I I found dad's
letter um she's like but I don't think
it's going to hold up in
court and I said so what did he say he
said that um he Beque you
$1 because you already received your
inheritance and then he left my son
$155,000 which was the balance of his
bank
account when he stopped talking to me
and so that was like an even lower
blow that he wrote that after he got out
of prison so in 2020 he still was mad at
me and still was bitter with
me however I think the only thing that
gives me peace about him
is about six months before he died I
checked my old Facebook cuz I hadn't
even used that old Facebook Facebook I
didn't want to be but I checked it and
he had sent me a message on
Facebook and at least I was able to tell
him I love
him so he knew that which was good it's
the only thing that gives me peace about
his
death but when I found the letters I
wrote to him the other day looking
through some stuff and I saw that letter
of me like supporting him building him
up I'll never leave you Dad I'll be here
for you
then the letter he wrote to me I read
right after and it said I need for you
to take this money I need you to take
the safe and take it to your moms and I
need for you to do this with it was all
about money and I instantly got
angry cuz I'm
like money was more
important than me and your
grandson I don't know that lifestyle is
more
important and you know there's a lot of
people on your channel who sell drugs
and pin and do all that stuff but they
don't understand how it affects their
family they might think that they're
taking care of their family and that's
the purpose they're why they're doing
it but if something happens to them it
affects their whole family their whole
family's life are affected I was in
prison well right along with my dad I
ran his life for him through him I had
no life you need to do this for me you
need to you know rep place the roof you
need to go do this you need to go do
that why aren't you answering the phone
I got to call you it's 7:00 every day
why aren't you answering did you send
money on my books did you like it was
not did you send me clothes did you I
had to drive 4 hours every other weekend
to go visit him my entire life up until
2015 from 2009 to 2015 was all my dad
and then I had this leech living in my
house awful human being just sucking all
the emotional everything out of me and
I'm trying to to raise a good son trying
to shelter him from all this bad [__]
and his mom going completely insane
around him it was like this
whole whirlwinds of [__] was going
around in my
son and you know when he moved out after
he moved out he finally told me
like What affected him growing up and he
actually told me that he thought it
would be better for him to never be born
because then I wouldn't have had to work
so hard in my life I didn't realize that
telling him you're the reason why I've
worked so hard you're the reason why I'm
still here you're the reason why I'm he
feels bad that I've had to work so hard
because of him but in actuality he's
what saved
me he say he saved me when I got
pregnant with him I don't think if I
would have had him I probably would have
killed myself many years before but I
couldn't do that to
him um but anyways back to that drug
dealers don't think about their families
they don't think about their safety they
don't they don't you know if you leave
money for your family good that's that's
good if I'm going to say to anything to
any drug dealers listen to me leave them
some money somewhere you know so they
have a nest egg be smart don't let them
get involved in
youru keep your family safe and it's not
worth it it's not worth all the tears
and and the heartache you're doing more
harm than good yeah I benefited from the
money and the trips and I and the makeup
and the jewelry and I loved it and I had
a great
time but I would have rather have had my
dad so I'm in a good place now and I
hope to
continue um learning and getting better
and dealing with my mental health and
hopefully I find a career and do good in
my job right now I don't have anything
I'm dirt poor I'm broke I'm doing the
job that I've always wanted to do
helping people um something my mom said
I was an idiot for for trying to do I'd
never make money she was right I'm about
to lose everything all over again I'm
but I'm smiling this time so hopefully I
continue to do well and flourish that's
my my only wish for myself going forward
you deserve it thank you all right
Christina thank you so much for sharing
your story yep thank
you